Speaker 1: All right. Something, something really,
really bad for our show happened yesterday.
As many of you know, we have been covering every
day of the Kyle Rittenhouse trial in Kenosha,
Wisconsin. And these are long days we've been
doing the show and streaming close to the fall
proceedings in court in Kenosha. I think it's an
important case. I think it's an interesting case.
Somewhere between 100000 and 150000 different
people each day are checking out our coverage,
which has been on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook.
We have been banned by Twitch for 30 days and we
have been banned by Twitch for 30 days for showing
something which other channels also showed,
including right wing channels, which I'm not
going to name because this isn't about getting
other people in trouble. And that something
is that yesterday, during the proceedings,
during the testimony of an individual named
Gaige Grosskreutz, an exhibit was put up by
the prosecution, which was about eight
or 10 seconds of video of Grosskreutz
after being shot in the bicep. And his bicep is
bloody. It is gory, and it was about eight or 10
seconds of that. We believe, because of immediate
reporting by what we call antagonist watchers that
watch my stream to Twitch. Within about a minute
or two, our account was suspended for 30 days.
Now the reason I say it was probably because
of people immediately reporting us. We have a,
you know, we have a close to 100000 followers
on Twitch. I don't or we did. I don't think
Twitch is watching our stream and the fact that
it happened so quickly and that other channels,
including right wing channels who showed
the same video have not been banned
suggests to me that was the reason. Now this
is I'm not going to exaggerate, but I'm not
going to downplay it. This is really bad for us.
We've spent basically two plus years since August
of 2019 building our following on Twitch in my
my model of diversifying revenue streams because
we've seen YouTube will take away, you know that
who giveth sometimes taketh away. We've lost all
of our YouTube revenue for periods of a couple of
months. We've had issues with Facebook, et cetera,
close to 100000 followers. We had a thousand paid
members on Twitch because we are now suspended for
a month. None of those thousand paid subscriptions
will renew. For us, a thousand paid members is a
lot. What am I doing to try to fix this? First of
all, let me say. I realize that. Those eight to
10 seconds are against Twitch's guidelines
on gore and playing violent videos, etc..
We appealed the decision and said we are not
doing a stream of gore. We are not showing,
you know, these kind of violence porn videos.
We're showing a trial of newsworthy significance.
We're 40 hours into this trial and there were
eight seconds of a gory video. It is not our
intent to broadcast gore. And it, you know,
there are video games with dogs being cut in
half with chainsaws which are allowed now. I get
video games are different. It's not real. I would
also argue that it's gratuitous and not newsworthy
in video games, and I think it should be allowed
to be clear. I'm not attacking video games.
I want to be really, really clear about that.
But this is an important trial. We should be
allowed to show it. And if you're going to ban
us for it, you really have to ban everybody.
And Twitch has not applied that even handedly.
So we've appealed this to Twitch multiple times
on different grounds. We've not heard back.
I don't know whether that's likely to go anywhere,
but this really isn't good now. I do want to
address there are people writing in and saying,
David, you've been arguing in favor of platforms
being allowed to do this. These are their terms
of service and they're enforcing them.
I'm not making any legal issue here. I I
this is not a double standard. I stand by
that. Twitch is allowed to have terms of
service and to enforce them. Facebook is allowed
to have terms of service and to enforce them.
I just disagree with the enforcement. I'm not
going out and saying this should be against the
law. We've got to regulate Twitch. We've got
to take away their power. I just think that
they should reconsider how they enforce this on
our channel because it's both counter-productive
to public education about an important
trial. And our intent is not to be showing
gory video after gory video, it was eight seconds
out of 40 hours that we have streamed of this. So
for the people emailing me saying This is what
you get, David for, saying they should be able
to enforce terms of service. No, they should.
I'm just making the argument in my appeal that
this was not the right decision with regard to my
channel. If they say it was the right decision,
I'm not going to say they should be sued. I just
disagree with the decision that they made. So in
the interim, I would like it if people decided to
grab a membership on my website. These thousand
paid members, we lost on Twitch. It's really a big
hit. It really is a big hit. So I would love it if
you came over to join Pacman dot com grabbed a
membership there, and I'm going to keep people
posted as to what is going on. One last thing I
would love it if you respectfully contacted Twitch
and said something along the lines of please and
suspend David Pakman, his coverage of the trial
is a public service or whatever. Be polite, etc.
I can't give you an email for who to contact. I've
been told that in the past when people have said
emailed this this email address at Twitch. Twitch
considers that doxing because I I, the person gave
out an email. So I'm not going to tell you how to
contact Twitch. Figure it out on your own. How
to contact Twitch. It's not that difficult. And
maybe lobby for hour on suspension. I would really
appreciate that. I don't know what else we can do.